This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Think about the last time you were part of a brainstorming session. We just need to brainstorm five ideas. But to be safe, let's come up with 50. Let's make it 100. Maybe this was at work or at a planning meeting for a community organization. Just want to emphasize there's no bad ideas here. We're just brainstorming. Many people probably suggested ideas.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。回想一下你上次参加头脑风暴会议的情景。我们只需要想出五个点子。但为了保险起见，我们想50个吧。干脆100个吧。也许这是在工作中，或者是在社区组织的规划会议上。我只想强调，这里没有不好的点子。我们只是在进行头脑风暴。许多人可能都提出了各种点子。
Perhaps there was some discussion about which proposal was best. At the end, maybe everyone voted on the best idea. If your meeting was like most meetings, there was probably one kind of idea that was in short supply. How to do less. I remember a brainstorming session some years ago
也许大家还讨论了哪个方案最好。最后，可能所有人投票选出了最好的点子。如果你的会议和大多数会议一样，那么有一种点子很可能是严重匮乏的。那就是如何做到“做更少的事”。我记得几年前的一次头脑风暴会议，
where colleagues filled an entire wall with Post-it notes. When I looked at the Post-it wall later on, I was struck that almost none of the notes suggested that the organization could streamline projects or stop doing things that weren't working. All the ideas were about expansion, new projects. Today we ask why we often ignore one of the most powerful paths to innovation. When less is more, this week on Hidden Brain. Humans are curious and inventive creatures. Give us a problem and we will come up with solutions.
当时同事们在整面墙上贴满了便条。后来当我看着这面便条墙时，我震惊地发现，几乎没有一张便条建议组织可以简化项目，或者停止那些行不通的事情。所有的点子都关于扩张和新项目。今天我们探讨为什么我们经常忽视通往创新的最强有力途径之一。当“少即是多”时，本周锁定《隐藏的大脑》。人类是充满好奇心和创造力的生物。给我们一个问题，我们就会想出解决方案。
Usually this is a marvelous skill. Our drive to invent new things, generate new ideas, is responsible for great breakthroughs in science, technology and medicine. There are times, however, when our desire to come up with new solutions gets in the way of coming up with the best solutions. At the University of Virginia, Lydie Klotz has long been fascinated by the process of invention
通常这是一个了不起的技能。我们发明新事物、产生新想法的驱动力，造就了科学、技术和医学领域的伟大突破。然而，有时我们渴望提出新解决方案的愿望，反而阻碍了我们提出最佳解决方案。在弗吉尼亚州立大学，莉迪·克洛茨长期以来一直对发明过程着迷，
and an important component of invention that many of us overlook. Lydie Klotz, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks, Shankar. It's great to be here. Lydie, when you were an undergraduate trying to master the fundamentals of engineering, you initially adopted an approach to studying that will be familiar to many students.
以及一个我们许多人忽视的发明的重要组成部分。莉迪·克洛茨，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，尚卡尔。很高兴来到这里。莉迪，当你还是个本科生，试图掌握工程学基础知识时，你最初采用了一种许多学生都会感到熟悉的学习方法。
What was that approach, and how did it work out for you in your college course on mechanics? Yeah, so for those of listeners that have enough sense not to major in engineering, mechanics is this branch of physics that deals with objects at rest and in motion. And it requires you to go from plugging numbers into equations to actually visualizing how the concepts work in the world. And my approach to mechanics was the approach that I'd been using in all my courses up to
那是什么方法？它在你的大学力学课上对你有什么帮助？是的，对于那些足够理智而没有主修工程学的听众来说，力学是物理学的一个分支，研究静止和运动中的物体。它要求你从把数字代入公式，转变为真正想象这些概念如何在现实世界中运作。我学力学的方法，是我在那之前所有课程中一直在用的方法，那就是：好吧，弄清楚如何解决分配给我的家庭作业题，学会那个特定的问题，并尽量把尽可能多的这种题目塞进大脑，这样当考试来临时，我就更有可能在脑海中随时调出考试原题的精确复制品。随着学期推进，你的成绩怎么样？我得的是C。所以，我带着平均分C的成绩迎来了第三次考试，而且我一生中第一次面临不及格的危险。
that point, which was, okay, figure out how to solve the problems that I'd been using in all my courses up to that point, which was, okay, figure out how to solve the problems that I've been assigned for homework, learn that specific problem, and try to cram as many of those into my brain as possible, so that when the exam came about, I'd be more likely to have an exact replica of the problem that was on the exam already accessible in my brain. And how were you doing in terms of grades as the semester unfolded? I had a C average. And so I was coming, and it was serious.
如果发生这种情况，我要么不得不延误毕业进度，要求父母支付额外的学费在第二年重修这门课，要么就得转专业，转到一个不需要通过力学考试的专业。
I mean, I was coming into the third exam with the C average, and for the first time in my life, I was in danger of failing the course. And if that happened, I would either have to delay my degree progress and ask my parents to pay extra tuition to take the course the following year, or change my major to something that didn't require me to pass mechanics.
因此，在某个时候，当你考到这些烂成绩时，你提出了一个激进的、有些人可能会觉得冒险的方法来应对学期最后的阶段。你做了什么，莉迪？我真的只是剥离了我试图塞进大脑的那些无关紧要的东西。这门基础力学课实际上归结为应用牛顿第二运动定律。
So at one point, as you were getting these bad grades, you came up with a radical and some might say risky approach for the final portion of the semester. What did you do, Lydie? I just really stripped away the extraneous things that I was trying to cram into my brain. And this first mechanics class really just boils down to applying Newton's second law of motion.
因此，所有这些情况都可以用“力等于质量乘以加速度”来描述。我从这个公式就能推导出我需要的一切。所以在第三次考试之前，我不再死记硬背几十个其他公式和旁支斜出的概念。我不需要知道一堆力、质量和加速度。我只需要记住那个公式：F等于MA。所以你尝试了这个激进的方法。你参加了考试，教授发成绩的日子到了。
So all of these scenarios can be described by force equals mass times acceleration. And I could derive everything I needed from that equation. And so before that third exam, I stopped memorizing dozens of other equations and tangential ideas. I didn't need to know a bunch of forces and masses and accelerations. I just needed to remember that formula F equals MA. So you try this radical approach. You do the exam, and the day comes when the professor
给我描绘一下当时的情景吧。我永远不会忘记。我是说，这是维斯科姆教授，一个非常典型、人和善的工程学教授，但他有个习惯，就是发回试卷时，他会把最高分和最低分写在黑板上，好让大家对全班其他同学的考分有个概念。所以这次考试，他走进来，在黑板上写下98分和47分。然后他看着我，露出一副得意的神情，所有人都以为47分是我得的。
is handing out the grades. Paint me a picture of what happens. I'll never forget it. I mean, this is Professor Viscome, just a classic, nice engineering professor, but he had this thing where when he handed the exams back, he would write the highest and lowest score on the chalkboard to give you a sense of kind of how the rest of the class did. And so this exam he had, he comes in and he writes on the board a 98 and a 47. And then he looked at me and smirked and everybody assumed that I had gotten the 47.
我的同学们半开玩笑地，你知道的，在为我“庆贺”。我坐在那儿心想，好吧，既然我已经因为工程学不及格而被劝退了，我以后该选什么专业呢？当我拿到试卷时，我才明白他为什么会露出那种神情。因为拿98分的人是我。当莉迪把心思集中在更少的事情和核心概念上时，他考得更好。这是一段漫长旅程的开始，这段旅程让他认识到了在日常生活中做减法、削减和移除的价值。几年后，莉迪毕业、结婚并组建家庭后，他有了另一个顿悟的时刻。当时他和儿子埃兹拉一起用乐高积木搭桥。他当时三岁，我们正在用他的得宝积木（也就是大号乐高）搭一座桥，
My classmates were playfully, you know, cheering me. And I'm sitting there thinking about like, okay, now that I've failed out of engineering, what will my major be? And when I got my test back, I realized why he had smirked. And it was because I had earned the 98. Lydie did better when he focused his mind on fewer things, on core concepts. And it was the start of a long journey to recognize the value in everyday life of removing, of reducing, of subtraction. Some years later, after Lydie graduated, got married, and started a family, he had another moment of insight. He was building a bridge using Legos with his son Ezra. He was three at the time and we were building a bridge out of his Duplo blocks, the bigger Legos,
支撑塔的高度不一样，所以我们没法把桥面架上去，它们不在同一水平面上。当我转过身去看那座快要搭好的桥时，埃兹拉已经从较高的塔上拿掉了一个积木，所以，虽然我的冲动是给较矮的支柱添砖加瓦，但在那一刻我意识到，这并不是打造水平桥面的唯一途径。所以这个时刻以一种具体的方式向你展示了，我们当中有多少人低估了减法力量。据我了解，你向其他人展示了埃兹拉桥梁的复制品，
and the support towers were different heights so we couldn't span them, they weren't level. And as I turned back toward the soon-to-be bridge, Ezra had already removed a block from the taller tower, so whereas my impulse had been to add to the short support, in that moment I realized that it wasn't the only way to create a level bridge. So this moment captured in a concrete way for you how many of us underestimate the power of subtraction. And I understand you showed other people a replica
看看有多少人会想出拿掉一块积木而不是添加一块积木的主意。是的，学生们会来找我谈论他们的作业，我会把这座桥给他们看，看看他们会怎么做，结果每个人都像我一样往上加。然后我也把它拿给我的同事加布·亚当斯看，我想我一直都在和她讨论这些观点，而且她这人简直是个天才。所以我想，好吧，当我把这个给她时，她一定会做减法。
of Ezra's bridge to see how many of them came up with the idea of taking away a block instead of adding a block. Yeah, students would come to talk to me about their assignments, and I'd give them this bridge and see what they did, and everybody added, like me. And then I also took it to Gabe Adams, who's a professor colleague of mine, and I thought that I had been talking to her
于是我把它交给了她，结果她和一样我往上加。但后来我说：“嘿，这是埃兹拉做的。”她说：“哦，哦，哦，所以你一直想表达的意思是，你对‘为什么我们忽视减法作为改进事物的途径’很感兴趣。”
about these ideas, and plus she's, like, a genius. So I figured, okay, she's the one who's going to subtract here when I give her this. And so I give it to her and she added like me. But then when I said, hey, this is what Ezra did, she says, oh, oh, oh, so what you've been trying to say is that you're interested in why do we overlook subtraction as a way to improve things.
“减法作为改进事物的途径。”所以，莉迪，你开始痴迷于减法的价值。有些人甚至可能会说你变成了一个狂热分子。你开始从工程学和设计界收集例子，而且你偶然发现了20世纪初建筑师安娜·凯特莱恩的作品。跟我讲讲她的故事吧。哦，她是个迷人的人物。她是宾夕法尼亚州第一位获得执照的女建筑师。她上大学时打过篮球，是第一批开车出门的女性之一。她还是一位连续发明家，她做出了20世纪最具创意的进步之一。在安娜·凯特莱恩之前，建筑砖块都是实心的。所以如果你的房子有一百多年历史，它很可能是建立在实心砖之上的。在她的专利中——我想这是1927年的事——凯特莱恩发明了“K砖”，开始减去建筑砖块中的部分质量。她本质上做的是创造了一种空心砖，
subtraction as a way to improve things. So, so Lydie, you became obsessed with the value of subtraction. Some might even say you became a zealot. You started collecting examples from the worlds of engineering and design and, and you stumbled on the work of the early 20th century architect Anna Kitelein. Tell me her story. Oh, she's a fascinating person. She was the first female licensed architect in the state of Pennsylvania. She'd played basketball in college, was one of the
深知承重可以发生在砖块的外围部分。通过创造空心砖，与典型建筑砖块相比，你减少了一半的材料，这当然使它更便宜、更容易施工，运输所需的燃料也更少。然后这些空心砖还因为砖块内部的气穴提供了更多的隔热效果。因此，建造出来的房子更舒适、噪音更小、更不易着火，砖块本身也更便宜。她的这种减法洞察力自此经历了几次演变，但它催生了
first women to drive a car. She was also a serial inventor and she made one of the most ingenious advances of the 20th century. Before Anna Kline, building blocks were solid. So if your house is more than a century old, it probably rests on solid blocks. In her patent, and I think this was 1927, Kike line invented the K-brick, which started to subtract some of the mass from building blocks. What she essentially did was create a hollow block,
这种如今无处不在的建筑砖块。它被用来建造从学校和摩天大楼的外墙，到我那两层扩建部分的基墙等一切建筑。一旦我们熟悉了某个特定的物体，我们往往会寻找为它做加法的方法，而不是做减法。但拿掉一些东西的做法可以产生显著的结果。莉迪最喜欢的例子之一是一项被称为“斯特赖德滑步车（Strider bike）”的发明。莉迪最喜欢的例子之一是一项被称为“斯特赖德滑步车”的发明。这些是没有脚踏板的迷你自行车，基本上能让年仅一岁半的孩子骑自行车。它们的工作原理是：它们是小自行车，但不是靠链条和脚踏板推进的，而是靠幼儿用双腿滑行前进的。这就是为什么它们被称为斯特赖德滑步车。
knowing that the load bearing could happen on the outside parts of the block. And by creating the hollow block, you remove half the material compared to what was in the typical building block, which of course makes it less expensive and easier to build with and less fuel to transport. And then these hollow blocks also provide more insulation because of the air voids that are in the blocks. So the resulting buildings are more comfortable, less nosy, less prone to fire, and the block itself is less expensive. And her subtractive insight, it's since gone through several evolutions, but it's led to
发生的情况是，幼儿推动自行车向前滑行，有点像《摩登原始人》里的汽车。更让人印象深刻的是，一旦——一旦我的儿子长大了，不再适合骑斯特赖德滑步车了。一旦他决定是时候换大童自行车时，我们根本不用费心安装辅助轮。他已经知道如何保持平衡，他只需要学会如何踩脚踏板，当然还有如何刹车。儿童自行车作为一种独特的自行车类别被推销了将近一个世纪，
this building block that's now ubiquitous. It's used to build everything from the facades of schools and skyscrapers to the foundation walls for my two-story addition. Once we become familiar with a particular object, we tend to look for ways to add to it rather than to subtract from it. But the act of taking away can produce remarkable results. One of Leidy's favorite examples is an invention known as the Strider bike. One of Lydie's favorite examples is an invention known as the strider bike. These are the pedal-less mini bikes that basically allow kids as soon as one and a half years old to ride a bike. And the way they work, they're small bikes, but they're not propelled by chains and pedals, but by toddlers striding with their legs. That's why they're called strider bikes.
在这期间有大量的设计变更，对吧？辅助轮、更宽的轮胎、越来越多的变速档，你知道的，那些把儿童自行车像小火车尾车一样连接到大人自行车上的玩意儿。花了很长时间才有人产生这样的灵感：“嘿，如果我们减去脚踏板和传动系统，这会不会更好？”当他们想到这一点时，它让这种两轮自行车适合了一个全新的年龄段的儿童骑行，并且对他们的父母极具销售吸引力。所以后来你开始问自己，在看到这些例子后，如何将减法的洞察力应用到你自己的生活中。在某个时候，你对一个家居翻新项目提出了一个新颖的方法。
And what happens is the toddler propels the bike forward, kind of like a Flintstone cars. And what's even more impressive is once, once my, my son has since aged out of the Strider bike. And once he decided it was time for his big kid bike, we didn't have to bother with training wheels. He already knew how to balance and he just needed to learn how to push the pedals and of course to break. And children's bikes were marketed as their own distinct class of bicycle for almost a century,
你向你的学生们抛出一个不同寻常的挑战：一个设计竞赛。你称之为“通过减法实现加法”。你能向我描述一下这个挑战吗？当然。所以我们搬到了弗吉尼亚大学，搬来这里时我们把房子缩小了。这栋房子以前也是学生出租房。所以我们知道我们必须进行翻新。减法是首要考虑的事情。我想我职业上算是个工程师兼建筑师吧。
and there were plenty of design changes over that time, right? Training wheels, fatter tires, more and more speeds, you know, those contraptions that connect a kid's bike to a grown-up's like a caboose. And it took a really long time for somebody to have the insight of, hey, will this be better if we subtract the pedals and the drivetrain? And when they did think of it, it made these two-wheeled bikes rideable for a whole new age group and saleable to their parents. So later you began to ask yourself, after seeing these examples, how you could apply the insights of subtraction to your own life. And at one point you came up with a novel approach to a home renovation project.
所以我当时想：我们能在这里把减法付诸实践吗？因此我们竞赛的名字叫“通过减法实现加法”。我非常幸运能与非常聪明的学生共事，我为他们举办了一场设计竞赛。我们强调我们的目标是减法。我们甚至表示，如果翻新能通过减法表达某种理念，我们愿意支付更多费用。我提供了1000美元现金和免费饼干，几十个建筑、工程和环境设计专业的学生报了名。但是，这些学生想出了聪明的设计。有个学生发现了我们家里未被利用的垂直空间，
You threw down an unusual challenge to your students, a design contest. You called it addition by subtraction. Can you describe the challenge to me? Sure. So we moved to the University of Virginia and we downsized our home when we moved here. And the home had also been a student rental. And so we knew that we were going to have to do a renovation. Subtraction was top of mind. And I'm an engineer slash architect, I guess, by profession.
并利用它在埃兹拉的卧室里增加了一个挑高区域。还有个大三学生改变了我们后院的坡度，从而提供了通往地下室的外部通道，这把地下室变成了一个宜居的生活空间。还有一个研究生团队巧妙地重新配置了整个平面图。所有这些都会让我们的房子更宜居。然而，实际上并没有人做减法，对吧？没有人减去平方英尺。莉迪，在经历了整个发明过程的最后，你的家居翻新项目的最终结果是什么？
And so I was like, can we put subtraction into play here? And so the name of our contest was addition by subtraction. And I have the great fortune of working with really smart students for whom I ran a design contest. And we emphasized that our goal was to subtract. And we even said that we were willing to pay more if the renovation could make a statement through subtraction. And I offered a thousand dollars in cash and free cookies and a couple of dozen architecture, engineering, and environmental design type majors signed up. But the, and the students came up with clever designs. There was one student who found unused vertical space in, in our house and used
我妻子担心你会问这个。所以，因为现在我们有了一个由五间房、两层楼、900平方英尺组成的扩建部分，它从原本是一个小科德角式房屋的后方延伸出去。莉迪的设计竞赛最终作为产生减法点子的源头失败了。他发现，虽然减法可能是发明的强有力驱动因素，但许多强大的阻碍却挡在它前面。理解这些阻碍以及如何克服它们成了他的新痴迷。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。莉迪·克洛茨是弗吉尼亚大学的一名工程师。
that to add a lofted area to Ezra's bedroom. There was a junior who changed the grading of our backyard and that provided outside access to the basement, which then turned that into a viable living space. And there was this graduate student team that kind of intricately reconfigured the entire floor plan. And all of those things would have made our house more livable. And yet no one had actually subtracted, right? Nobody had taken away square footage. Lydie, at the end of this whole process of invention, what was the end result of your home renovation project?
他研究的是我们在解决问题时倾向于做加法的这种自动倾向。在一项明确旨在进行减法的家居翻新项目最终大大扩展了他那栋科德角式房屋的面积之后，莉迪开始探究为什么人类发现做减法如此困难。所以，莉迪，在这个家居翻新项目结束时，你被整个过程弄得有些谦卑，
My wife was worried you would ask. So, because now we have a five-room, two-story, 900-square-foot addition that extends from the rear of what had been a little Cape Cod. Leidy's design contest ultimately failed as a generator of ideas that would lead to subtraction. He discovered that while subtraction might be a powerful driver of invention, many powerful obstacles stand in its way. Understanding those obstacles and how to overcome them became his new obsession. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanatham. Lydie Klotz is an engineer at the University of Virginia.
但它也为你提供了一些重要的见解，让你明白为什么减去、移除、拿走是如此困难。特别是说到家居翻新，减法的一个阻碍是经济因素？是的，对我们来说，这意味着这是我们家庭最大的投资，房屋价值的某种经验法则——Zillow是怎么计算的，房产经纪人在评估时是怎么计算的——就是价值随着总平方英尺的增加而增加。
He studies our automatic tendency to add things when it comes to solving problems. After a home renovation project explicitly aimed at subtraction ended up greatly expanding the size of his Cape Cod home, Lydie started to ask why human beings find it so hard to subtract. So Lydie, at the end of this home renovation project, you were humbled by the process,
所以你知道的，2000平方英尺是一个价格。如果你有2500平方英尺，那就是另一个价格。而参加设计竞赛的人，莫妮卡和我怎么也无法找到一种方法来绕过这个财务现实。我是说，在不增加平方英尺的情况下花钱将是一笔非常冒险的投资。嗯，花钱去摆脱现有的平方英尺简直荒谬。
but it also gave you some important insights into why it is so hard to subtract, to remove, to take away. When it comes to home renovations in particular, one barrier to subtraction was economics? Yeah, for us, I mean, this is the biggest investment our family has and the kind of rule of thumb for homes values, how Zillow calculates it, how the realtors calculate it when they're appraising it, is that the value increases with the total square footage.
另一件事是，这并不是说减法总是正确的选择。拥有更多平方英尺对我们的家来说一直是有益的。我们的家庭在成长，我们确实需要更多平方英尺。所以这可能是一个减法并非更好选择的例子，尽管我们一开始的意图是这样的。我也在想，大概有这样一群人，你知道的，建筑师、建造商和承包商，他们所有人都是因为做了更多的事情而获得更多报酬，而不是因为做了更少的事情。
So you know, 2000 square foot, that's one price. If you have 2,500 square feet, that's another price. And entrance in the design competition and Monica and I could just never figure out a way past this financial reality. I mean, spending money without adding square footage would have been a really risky investment. Um, and spending money to get rid of existing square footage was preposterous.
完全正确。如果我们雇佣了承包商来减少空间，你知道的，他们是根据他们做翻新成本的百分比来获得报酬的。因此，减少空间的翻新成本更低，他们在这上面的间接费用就赚得更少。我也在想，在房屋翻新期间进行扩建也是一种文化上的预期，对吧？我是说，有多少人做翻新结果却得到一个更小的家？嗯，我是说，这个词本身就已经说明了一切，对吧？我是说，房屋翻新的同义词就是房屋增建。你从来没听过房屋减建。
Another thing was this was just, it's not that subtracting is always the right option. It has been beneficial to have more square footage in our home. Our family was growing, and we did need some more square footage. So this may have been a case where subtracting wasn't the better option, even though we started out with that as our intention. And I'm also thinking that presumably they were people, you know, architects and builders and contractors, and they all get paid more for
是的。所以当你开始思考实行减法的经济和文化阻碍时，你开始明白这些阻碍
doing more, not for doing less. Exactly. If we had hired a contractor to subtract space, you know, they're getting paid based on the percentage of how much it costs them to do the renovation. And so a less expensive renovation that subtracts space, they get less overhead on that. I'm also thinking that expanding during a home renovation is also what's sort of culturally expected, right? I mean, how many people do a renovation and end up with a smaller home? Well, I mean, it's right there of culturally expected, right? I mean, how many people do a renovation
在人类历史上由来已久。怎么说，莉迪？当然，在人类历史上，让我们从那开始。这就是纪念碑式建筑的概念。再次说明，我的背景是工程学。我喜欢宏大的结构。我很惊讶地了解到，人们认为——或者科学家们认为——纪念碑式建筑在文明发展中扮演了多么关键的角色。你所说的纪念碑式建筑是什么意思？它的定义字面意思就是它远远超出了必要的需求。因此，纪念碑式建筑的主要定义特征是：
and end up with a smaller home? Well, I mean, it's right there in the word, right? I mean, the synonym for home renovation is a home addition. You never hear of a home subtraction. Yeah. So as you started to think about the economic and cultural obstacles to practicing subtraction, you came to understand that such obstacles
其规模、宏大程度和细节超出了任何实际功能的要求。因此，美索不达米亚的通天塔、埃及和中国的金字塔，这些庞大但实用价值微乎其微的结构，与它们周围的城市几乎同时发展起来。即使在今天，你也可以争辩说，在现代世界中，你知道的，当人们做加法而不是做减法时，他们在资源和地位上会得到回报。
reach very far back into human history. How so, Lydie? Certainly, in human history, let's start there. That's this concept of monumental architecture. And again, my background's engineering. I like big structures. I was surprised to learn about how key a role people think, or the scientists scientists think monumental architecture played in the development of civilization. What do you mean by monumental architecture? It's literally defined by the fact that it adds well beyond what is necessary. So the principal defining feature of monumental architecture is that the
我们为建造摩天大楼的人树立纪念碑和牌匾，而不是为拆除它们的人这样做。完全正确。我是说，例如，在大学校园里这是一个巨大的挑战。获得捐赠来建造一个带有他们家族名字的建筑物，要比获得捐赠来拆除某样东西——甚至是为了某种不会留下一个人慷慨大方的巨大物理提醒的东西——要容易得多。捐赠者希望将他们的资金投入到切实的事务中，这合情合理。政客们同样希望能够剪彩，以宣传他们为选民提供的新便利设施。在一片空地上剪彩是很困难的。这些都是微妙地促使我们偏爱加法而非减法的文化和政治力量。在所有这些例子中，
scale and you know elaboration and detail exceed the requirements of any practical functions. So the ziggurats in Mesopotamia, the pyramids of Egypt and China, these massive but marginally useful structures kind of grew at the same time as the cities around them. And even today, you could argue that in a modern world, you know, people are rewarded in terms of resources
我的意思是，问题在于做减法需要更多的工作。这是更多的脑力劳动。正如我们所讨论的，它涉及更多步骤。而且它的成果更少。所以在你做了所有这些额外的工作之后，你得到的证据却更少了，因为你所做的事情根据定义已经消失了。所以我听说你的雇主，弗吉尼亚大学，
and status when they add as opposed to when they subtract. We have markers and plaques for the people who build skyscrapers, not for the people who take them down. Exactly. I mean, that's a huge challenge on university campuses, for example. It's so much easier to get a donation for somebody to create a building that has their family's name on it than to, you know, a donation for removing something or for even for something that doesn't
曾经征求关于如何改进大学的建议，而你最终分析了收到的建议。你发现了什么，莉迪？是的，我们在新校长上任时进行了一次最新的战略规划工作，它和以往一样，通过向学生、教职员工、社区成员、校友和捐赠者征求意见来开始。他们基本上都在为如何改进大学提出自己的点子。我们拿到了这些数据，正如预期的那样，做加法的呼声极其猖獗。我是说，人们想要更多的海外留学资助、更多的心理健康服务、
come with this big physical reminder of the person's generosity. It makes sense that donors want to put their money behind something tangible. Politicians similarly want to be able to cut a ribbon to tout a new amenity that they're delivering for their constituents. It's hard to cut a ribbon on an empty field. These are the sorts of cultural and political forces that subtly push us to favor addition over subtraction. Across all of these examples,
照顾国际学生的设施、更多的住房选择。有人要求建一个新的冰球场，我以前不知道我们这里有冰球队，但我假设这也是一种进步。但关键是，这里肯定有未被开发的潜力，因为在关于改变大学的750个点子里，只有不到10%的人建议拿掉某些东西。是的。我想把注意力转向组织内部发生的事情，
I mean, the problem is that subtracting is more work. It's more mental work. It's more kind of steps as we're talking about it. And there's less to show for it. And so after you do all this extra work, you have less evidence because the thing that you've done is by definition disappeared. So I understand that your employer, the University of
例如，当我们围坐在桌旁进行头脑风暴时。我觉得经常有很大的压力去增加东西，而几乎没有任何动力去减少。所以围坐在桌边的每个人都希望自己的点子被实施。有礼貌的人不想扼杀同事的点子。因此，最终的结果是一堆新项目、新计划，大量的加法。当然。
Virginia, once asked for suggestions on how the university could be improved, and you ended up analyzing the recommendations that came in. What did you find, Lydie? Yeah, we had a new latest strategic planning effort with a new president, and it began as these tend to by soliciting ideas from students, faculty, staff, community, alumni members, donors. And all of them were basically offering their ideas for how to improve the university. We got our hands on the data and as expected, the adding was ramp rampant. I mean people wanted more study abroad grants, more mental health
有礼貌的因素。还有就是，在你不了解组织运作方式之前，不跑过来指手画脚说“这是我们绝对应该从这个组织中减掉的东西”，这其实是一个很好的决策捷径。对吧？我是说，在你不了解冰球队是如何为大学做贡献的、冰球队的历史等等情况之前，有人说“嘿，让我们解散冰球队吧”，这太冒失了。
services, teller to international students, more housing options. There was a request for a new ice arena and I didn't know we had a ice hockey team here but I assume that's progress too. But the thing is surely there was untapped potential because out of 750 ideas for changing the university, fewer than 10% suggested taking something away. Yeah. I want to turn my attention to what happens within organizations when
要添加某样东西，你可以直接说：“嗯，这会让任何事情变得更好，所以让我们把它加到我其实并不太了解的系统里吧。”我听说你还研究了做加法甚至如何具有生物学根基。跟我讲讲斯蒂芬妮·普雷斯特（Stephanie Preston）的研究吧。是的，斯蒂芬妮是我最喜欢的研究人员之一。她是密歇根大学的心理学家，
we're having brainstorming sessions around a table, for example. I feel like there's often a lot of pressure to add and almost no incentive to subtract. So everyone sitting around the table wants their idea implemented. Polite people don't want to shoot down ideas from their colleagues. And so the net result is a pileup of new programs, new projects, a ton of additions. Certainly.
她比任何人都更清楚她所谓的“占有欲”，也就是我们如何以及为什么获取并保留东西。例如，她我最喜欢的实验之一是：向参与者随机且逐个展示一百多种不同的物体。然后，随着每个物体出现在屏幕上，参与者被问及他们是否愿意虚拟获取它。
There's politeness. And then there's also just, it's kind of a good decision making shortcut to not come in and say, oh, here's something we definitely should subtract from this organization until you understand how the organization works. Right. I mean, so it's pretty bold for somebody to say, hey, let's get rid of the ice hockey team before you understand how, you know, what they're contributing to the university, the history of the ice hockey team and so on and so forth.
这全是想象出来的。他们知道自己实际上不会得到这些东西。他们可以根据自己的意愿获取任意多或任意少的东西。这些物体的实用性各不相同。所以有些东西像香蕉、咖啡杯和延长线，这些可能是你会捡起来的东西。其他东西看起来用处不大，但人们仍然会捡起来，比如空的两升装瓶子、用过的便利贴、过时的报纸。
To add something, you can just say, well, this would make anything better, so let's add it to our system that I don't really understand. I understand that you've also looked at how adding could even have biological roots. Tell me about the work of Stephanie Preston. Yeah, Stephanie's one of my favorite researchers. She's a psychologist at the University of Michigan,
一旦他们对这100个物体中的每一个都做出了选择，参与者就会看到他们添加的所有东西。所以如果你获取了70样东西，屏幕上会同时显示所有这70样东西，然后他们被鼓励去做减法。接着，他们面临的挑战是削减他们的藏品，以便它可以装进
and she knows more than anybody about what she calls acquisitiveness, which is how and why we get and keep things. So, for example, one of my favorite studies of hers, participants are shown more than a hundred different objects in random order and one at a time. And then as each object appears on the screen, participants are asked whether they would like to acquire it virtually.
电脑屏幕上的一个购物车里。最后，他们被要求把它变得更小，以便它可以装进一个虚拟的纸质杂货袋里。所以目标非常明确。所有东西都必须装进一个杂货袋里，否则你就无法完成任务。屏幕上会显示实时的反馈，告诉你是否已经减掉了足够的东西。
It's all imaginary. They know they won't actually get these things. And they can acquire as many or as few as they want. And the objects vary in their usefulness. So there are things like bananas and coffee mugs and extension cords, things you might pick up. Others seem less useful, but people do still pick up, like empty two-liter bottles, used sticky notes, outdated newspapers.
很多参与者都没能把它精简到一个袋子。许多人甚至连购物车那一关都过不了。我听说还有关于当我们参与加法或减法时大脑内部发生的研究。这项研究显示了什么，莉迪？神经科学家研究这一点的方法之一是，在人们获取东西时，将他们连接到脑部成像机器上。因此，食物获取以及其他类型的
And once they have made a choice about each of these 100 objects, participants are then shown everything that they've added. So if you've acquired 70 things, you're shown all 70 things together on the screen, and then you're encouraged to subtract. Then they're challenged to whittle down their collection so that it can fit into a shopping cart
获取，都会激活大脑中的同一奖励系统。因此，这个通路基本上连接了我们大脑中思考和感受的部分。这就是进食让人感到愉悦的原因；
on the computer screen. And finally, they're asked to make it even smaller so that it can fit into one virtual paper grocery bag. So the goal is very clear. Everything needs to fit into one grocery bag or else you don't complete the task. And you're getting real-time feedback displayed on the screen of whether you've subtracted enough stuff.
嗯，正如我们所知，它也可以被诸如可卡因之类的药物，以及让我们不断点击和滚动的网站设计所刺激；嗯，然后对于囤积者来说，甚至用过的便利贴也能刺激这种奖励系统通路。所以，嗯——因此，当你确实发现这样一个特定的奖励系统在发挥作用时，它证实了我们进行加法的倾向可能是多么根深蒂固。所以你也进行了一系列实验，揭示了你所谓的“减法忽视”（subtraction neglect），即忽视减法力量的倾向，其中一个实验的灵感来自于你在旅行方面与妻子长期存在的争论。你能给我一个这个争论的具体验证吗，莉迪？
And a lot of participants fail to get it down to a single bag. And many don't even make it past the shopping cart. I understand there's also been research into what happens inside the brain when we engage in addition or engage in subtraction. What does that research show, Lydie? One way that the neuroscientists have studied this is hooking people up to their brain imaging machines while they're acquiring things. And so food acquisition, as well as other types
嗯，所以，是的，我们有时会去外滩（Outer Banks），那是北卡罗来纳州外海的岛屿。所以你的一天可能会是这样的：去看基蒂霍克（Kitty Hawk），看看莱特兄弟大展身手的地方。
of acquisition, activate this same reward system in the brain. So this pathway connects basically the thinking and the feeling parts of our brain. And this is what makes it pleasurable to eat. Um, and it can also be stimulated as we know, by drugs like cocaine, uh, website designs that keep us clicking and scrolling. Um, and then for hoarders, even the used sticky notes can kind of stimulate this reward pathway.
去看看沙滩，去外面吃顿饭，你可以开车到处看看所有的灯塔，或者你也可以顺其自然，也许在海滩上找找贝壳，看看午餐吃什么，
So that's, um, and so when you do find that a specific reward system like this one is playing a role, it confirms just how deep-rooted some of our tendency to add might be. So you've also conducted a whole bunch of experiments that reveal what you call subtraction neglect, a tendency to ignore the power of subtraction, and one of them was inspired by a long-running debate you've had with your wife when it comes to travel. Can you give me a concrete example of this debate
在那里度过一个计划没那么满的一天。所以我更倾向于后一种度假方式。我妻子莫妮卡则喜欢把尽可能多的活动塞进行程里。据我了解，你实际上做过实验，也许就是基于你一直在进行的这场关于人们如何看待旅行的夫妻争论。跟我讲讲那些实验吧，莉迪。
in action, Lydie? Well, so yeah, we go to the Outer Banks sometimes, and that's the islands off of North Carolina. And so your day can look something like going to look at Kitty Hawk and see where the Wright brothers did their thing. And there's, their thing and go see some sand dunes and you can go out to eat and you could drive down and look at all the lighthouses or you could kind of just let the day come to you and maybe do some looking for shells on the beach and see what happens for lunch
嗯，这算不上争论。我是说，她是正确的，对吧？所以算不上。但这甚至比莫妮卡会安排的任何行程还要糟糕。所以我们为在华盛顿特区度过的一天创建了这个行程。所以现在我们又回到了实验世界。在14个小时的时间里，这个行程让参与者参观主要的旅游景点，如白宫、国家大教堂、老邮局，然后让他们在林肯纪念碑和退伍军人纪念碑等各种纪念碑前表达敬意，然后参观博物馆、购物，并在五星级小酒馆吃午餐。
and have a less scheduled day there. And so I'm more on the prefer the latter kind of vacation. My wife, Monica, likes to pack in as many activities as possible. And I understand that you've actually run studies, perhaps based on this marital dispute you've been having when it comes to how people think about travel. Tell me about those experiments, Lydie.
因此，所有这些站点之间的旅行时间就会超过两小时，假设华盛顿特区的交通状况达到最佳状态——而这种情况从未发生过。参与者在计算机屏幕上的拖放界面中看到了这个最初的行程。他们可以通过重新安排、
Well, it's not a dispute. I mean, she's right, right? So it's not. But this is worse than even anything Monica would schedule. So we created this itinerary for a day spent in Washington, D.C. So now we're back in the experimental world again. And over the course of 14 hours, this itinerary had participants visiting major tourist sites like the White House, the National Cathedral, the old post office, and then have them paying their respects at the various memorials like the Lincoln and
添加和减少活动来改变他们的行程。即便面对这个塞得满满当当的行程，每四个参与者中也只有一个人从原本密集的行程中删去了活动。哇。那其他人呢？嗯，有些人重新安排了，但大多数人进行了添加。他们往这个行程里添加了内容？这怎么可能？不可能。我是说，根本没有时间，但你可以收集某些东西，你知道的，拖放另一个任务。当他们看到其他任务坐在旁边时，这很有诱惑力。我想他们当时在想：“哦，看，那会是一件很有趣的事。”
the Veterans Memorial, and then a museum visit, shopping, and lunch at a five-star bistro. So just travel time between all these SOPs would exceed two hours, assuming optimal DC traffic, which never happens. Participants saw this original itinerary in kind of a drag-and-drop interface on the computer screen. And they could change their itinerary by rearranging,
这和战略规划有点相似。你会想：“好吧，添加更多好东西总是好的。”而在这种情况下，它只会让整体日程变得更加不可能、更加拥挤、更加令人不快。你还进行了另一个实验，其灵感来自于你在自己写作中遇到的困难。
adding, and subtracting activities. And even with this jam-packed itinerary, only one in four participants removed activities from the packed original. Wow. And what did the rest do? Well, some rearranged, but most added. They added to this it and area? How is that even possible? It isn't. I mean, there's not time, but it was possible to kind of collect something, you know, drag and drop another task. And it was enticing when they saw the other tasks sitting in there on the side. I think they were thinking, oh, look, that would be a fun thing to do.
跟我讲讲你在自己写作中面临的挑战以及你进行的实验吧。跟我讲讲你在自己写作中面临的挑战以及你进行的实验吧，莉迪。任何花时间在纸上或屏幕上玩弄文字的人都听过这个建议，对吧？《风格的要素》（Strunk and White）是大学和高中教学大纲中最常指定的教科书，他们经典的建议是：“省略多余的词”，
And it's kind of the same as the strategic planning. You think, OK, adding more good stuff is always good, and in this case, it was just gonna make the overall schedule even more impossible and more crowded and less pleasant. There's another study you conducted that was inspired by a difficulty you encountered in your own writing.
编辑是让你的写作更清晰的方法，然而这很明显是一种减法形式，对吧？你拿走了你创造的东西，现在你在把东西减掉。所以我们给人们看了一篇短文的摘要，然后问：“你将如何改进它？”结果只有17%的人最终从原文中删减了字词。总的来说，他们通过添加内容来让摘要变得更好。我听说同样的事情也适用于人们对食谱的看法，例如他们是如何烹饪的，
Tell me about the challenge that you have faced in your own writing and the study you conducted in your own writing. Tell me about the challenge that you have faced in your own writing and the study you conducted, Lydie. Anybody who spends time playing with words on paper on a screen has heard the advice, right? Strunk in white, they're the most assigned textbook on college and high school syllabi and their classic advice is, omit needless words,
同样的理念是加法而不是减法？哦，是的，我们在非常多的语境中都发现了这一点。我是说，当人们改进一个五成分的食谱时，90名参与者中只有2个人做了减法。当他们重构音乐音符循环时，他们更有可能添加音符而不是减去音符。所以我们在许多不同的语境中都发现了这一点。
that editing is the way to make your writing more clear and yet that's very obviously a form of subtracting right you're you're taking something that you've created and now you're taking things away from it so we gave people a summary of an article and said how would you make this better and only 17% ended up subtracting words from the original. So by and large, they added to make the summaries better. And I understand the same thing applies when you look at how people think about recipes, for example, how they're cooking,
广告休息。我们回来后将讨论对抗阻碍减法实现的障碍的技术。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。工程师莉迪·克洛茨坚信，如果我们更经常地进行减法，而不是总是选择做加法，我们的世界将会变得更好。问题是，进行减法存在许多心理障碍。
the same idea addition rather than subtraction? Oh yeah, we found this in so many contexts. I mean, people improving a five ingredient recipe, two out of 90 participants subtracted. When they transformed loops of musical notes, they were more likely to add notes than to take them away. So this was, we found this across many different contexts. ["The Hustle of the Heart"]
然而，有时进行减法的机会会出现，而莉迪表示，聪明的人和聪明的社区会抓住这样的机会。莉迪，请告诉我旧金山内河码头高速公路（Embarcadero Freeway）的故事。
When we come back, techniques to battle the obstacles that stand in the way of subtraction. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Engineer Lydie Klotz is convinced that our world would be a better place if we engaged more often in subtraction instead of always choosing to add. The problem is there are many psychological obstacles to subtraction.
是的，就像美国许多其他穿城高速公路一样，内河码头高速公路建于二战之后，它的修建得到了联邦对高速公路支持的资助，旨在运送军队并满足日益增长的汽车数量。它沿着东部海滨延伸了一英里多，挡住了珍贵的风景和通往海湾的通道。因此，规划人员开始思考：这付出的代价是不是比它带来的增加还要多？最后，规划委员会表示——这是在80年代中期——我们应该拆除内河码头高速公路。
There are times however when opportunities for subtraction open up and Lydie says smart people and smart communities seize on such opportunities. Lydie, tell people and smart communities seize on such opportunities. Lydie, tell me the story of San Francisco's Embarcadero Freeway. Yeah, like so many other city crossing highways in the United States, the Embarcadero Freeway was built after World War II,
公众对此有何反应？不太好。但这个提案实际上付诸了表决，而且票数并没有一边倒。支持拆除的选民每有一位，就有两名选民希望保留它。无论是因为对交通的恐惧、对生意受损的恐惧、还是对改变的恐惧，选民们都拒绝了它。民意已经表达得很清楚了。我是说，所以规划委员会基本上向前看，把重点放在了其他项目上。
and it was made possible by federal support for highways to move the military and serve the growing number of automobiles. It stretched for more than a mile along the eastern waterfront, and it blocked precious views and access to the bay. And so planners started to think, well, is this costing more than it's adding? And finally, the planning commission said, and this is in the mid-'80s, we should get rid of the Embarcadero
因此，在1986年的投票之后，拆除高速公路并开放海滨的可能性似乎已经破灭了。然后，在1989年10月17日发生了一件事。我是泰德·科佩尔（Ted Koppel）。北加州发生了一场相当强烈的地震，强烈到它除其他事情外，切断了棒球世界大赛第三场比赛举办地烛台球场的所有电力，但在总体计划中，这可能是最微不足道的
freeway. And what was the public reaction to this? Not good. But this one actually got put to a vote and it wasn't even close. For every voter in favor of removing it, there were two who wanted to keep it. And whether it was for fear of traffic, fear of lost business, fear of change, voters rejected it. And the people had spoken. I mean, so the Planning Commission basically moved on and focused on other projects.
高速公路。公众对此有何反应？不太好。但这次实际上付诸了表决，而且差距悬殊。每有一个投票赞成拆除的选民，就有两个想保留它。无论是出于对交通的恐惧、对商业损失的恐惧还是对改变的恐惧，选民们都拒绝了它。民意已经表达得很清楚了。我的意思是，规划委员会基本上转移了阵地，把重点放在了其他项目上。
So following the 1986 vote, it seemed that the possibility of tearing down the freeway and opening up the waterfront was dead. And then something happened on October 17th, 1989. I'm Ted Koppel. There has been a rather strong earthquake in Northern California so strong in fact that it has among other things knocked out all the power at Candlestick Park where the third game of the World Series was being played but in the overall scheme of things that may be the very least of
因此，在1986年的投票之后，拆除高速公路并开放海滨的可能性似乎已经破灭。然后，在1989年10月17日，发生了一件事。我是特德·科佩尔。北加州发生了一场相当强烈的地震，强烈到甚至切断了烛台公园的所有电力，世界大赛的第三场比赛当时正在那里举行，但在整个计划中，这可能只是其中微不足道的一部分
things that has happened today. So this was the Loma Prieta earthquake and of course the earthquake was a terrible thing it caused a lot of damage but it may have had one unexpected benefit. It changed how people thought about the Embarcadero freeway. How so? Well a number of ways. So it the earthquake killed more than 60 people and injured thousands. A lot of the deaths actually happened on a similar double-decker highway.
今天发生的种种。所以这就是洛马普里塔地震，当然地震是一件可怕的事情，它造成了巨大的破坏，但它可能带来了一个意想不到的好处。它改变了人们对内河码头高速公路的看法。怎么说呢？嗯，有很多方面。这次地震造成60多人死亡，数千人受伤。许多死亡其实发生在另一条类似的双层高速公路上。
The Cypress Street viaduct in Oakland. And so people seeing this double-decker elevated concrete structure just over a mile in length, it looked ominously like the Embarcadero. And then it also gave people a view of what life would be like if you didn't have the Embarcadero, because the Embarcadero didn't collapse during the earthquake, but it was rendered unusable for a while. And so people saw that they found other ways to get around the city, and that it didn't kind of totally ruin life in San Francisco
奥克兰的赛普里斯街高架桥。因此，人们看到这座双层高架混凝土结构，长度刚过一英里，看起来很不祥地像内河码头高速公路。这也让人们看到了如果没有内河码头高速公路，生活会是什么样子，因为内河码头高速公路在地震中没有倒塌，但有一段时间无法使用。人们看到他们找到了其他出行方式，而且这并没有彻底毁掉旧金山的生活
to not have the Embarcadero. And then what finally came of all of this, Lydie? It was still, it wasn't, like, this was by no means a unanimous choice. I mean, there's a famous Pulitzer Prize winning San Francisco Chronicle columnist and his name's Herb Kane and he's such an influential columnist. And even after the earthquake, as people brought this discussion back up,
没有内河码头高速公路的生活。那么这一切最终的结果是什么呢，莉迪？它依然……这并不是说，这绝不是一个一致的选择。我的意思是，有一位著名的普利策奖得主、《旧金山纪事报》专栏作家，他的名字叫赫布·凯恩，他是一位非常有影响力的专栏作家。甚至在地震发生后，当人们重新提起这个讨论时，
he has this great quote, "'Once again, there's serious talk about tearing down the Embarcadero Freeway, an even worse idea than building it. And so there was still resistance, but eventually the freeway came down, and when it was removed, they got the waterfront back. They saw an increase in housing, increase in jobs. It didn't cause traffic nightmare.
他有一句名言：“又有人在严肃讨论拆除内河码头高速公路了，这甚至比建造它还要糟糕。”因此当时仍然存在阻力，但最终这条高速公路还是被拆除了，当它被移除后，他们找回了滨水区。他们看到住房增加，工作岗位增加。它并没有引发交通噩梦。
Trips were rerouted. And if you've ever visited there, it's one of the most visited places in the world, and it's obvious why it shouldn't be covered with the freeways. So it took about 10 years, but by 2000, kind of the 10-year anniversary of the demolition, The Chronicle was then reporting that it was hard to find anyone who thinks ripping down the freeway was a bad idea. So we've had a crisis of our own the last couple of years that have forced a lot of us to think about what we do, where we work, how we work. How might the COVID-19 pandemic serve as a potential driver of subtraction, Lydie?
行程被重新规划。如果你曾去过那里，它是世界上游客最多的地方之一，原因显而易见，它不应该被高速公路覆盖。所以这花了大约10年时间，到2000年，也就是拆除工作的10周年之际，《旧金山纪事报》随后报道称，很难再找到任何人认为拆除这条高速公路是个坏主意。因此，过去几年我们迎来了我们自己的危机，这迫使我们许多人思考我们的所作所为、我们在哪里工作、我们如何工作。新冠肺炎疫情如何能成为减法的潜在驱动力呢，莉迪？
Yeah, I mean, I think at horrific cost, it's given us this singular chance for change and forced us to subtract in ways that we never would have managed on our own. And certainly I don't advocate subtracting family visits and friendly hugs, but we've also had to get rid of things like buffets and commutes and evictions and even carbon emissions. So I think that the crises interrupts this normal
是的，我的意思是，我认为是以惨重的代价，它为我们提供了一个千载难逢的变革机会，迫使我们以靠我们自己永远无法做到的大幅度来做减法。当然，我不主张删减家庭探访和友好的拥抱，但我们也不得不摆脱诸如自助餐、通勤、驱逐甚至碳排放之类的事情。所以我认为危机打断了这种正常
flow of things and shows us what a world with some of these subtractions might look like. You know, isn't it interesting that so often we actually need the external push before we can, before we see the value in subtraction? You know, we've talked about earthquakes, we've talked about a pandemic. I mean, you can think of a forest fire the same way. It's obviously not a good thing when you have a forest fire, but you know the removal of old growth might be helpful for new growth to happen in a forest. When I'm thinking about you know the marketplace for example, you know businesses go
事物的流动，向我们展示了一个拥有其中某些减法结果的世界会是什么样子。你知道，很有意思的是，通常情况下，我们需要外部的推动，才能看到减法的价值，对吧？你知道，我们谈论过地震，我们谈论过大流行病。我的意思是，你可以用同样的方式来看待森林大火。发生森林大火显然不是一件好事，但你知道移除老龄林可能对森林中新树木的生长有所帮助。当我想到市场时，比如，你知道企业会
out of business, you know stores go out of business because they kind of attract customers or they're selling stuff that people no longer want. And of course it's painful if you happen to be the store owner whose business is going bankrupt. But the net effect of this is that you know it gives another business a chance to sort of spring up. But in each of these cases it's interesting that we almost need the external force in order to for us to see the value of subtraction. It's almost it's so emotionally difficult for us to do the subtraction ourselves that we almost, it's so emotionally difficult for us to do the subtraction
倒闭，你知道商店会倒闭，因为它们吸引顾客的方式不再奏效，或者它们在卖人们不再想要的东西。当然，如果你恰好是那个面临破产的店主，这会很痛苦。但这样做的净效应是，你知道，它给其他企业提供了一个蓬勃发展的机会。但在每一种情况下，有趣的是，我们几乎需要外部力量才能让我们看到减法的价值。我们自己去做减法几乎是如此的在情感上困难，以至于我们几乎……我们自己去做减法在情感上是如此困难，
ourselves, that we need almost an external executioner to come in and do the hard stuff for us. Yeah, emotionally and cognitively difficult. And even if you look at evolution as a metaphor, the way that it works is through adaptation and then selection. So adaptation is an ad, and then the selection is a subtractionion and they're working hand in hand. And I think another fundamental disadvantage that's coming into play here is that we don't get as many reminders of subtraction, right?
以至于我们需要几乎一个外部的“刽子手”进来为我们做这些艰难的事情。是的，在情感和认知上都很困难。即使你把进化作为一个隐喻，它运作的方式也是通过适应然后是选择。所以适应是一个加法，然后选择是一个减法，它们是携手并进的。我认为这里发挥作用的另一个根本劣势是，我们没有得到那么多的减法提醒，对吧？
Because when something is added, there it is, right in front of you as evidence that this, adding this thing was a way to make change. If something was subtracted, in the rare cases thing is added, there it is right in front of you as evidence that this adding this thing was a way to make change. If something was subtracted in the rare cases that we do it and follow through with it, it's by definition gone. So as we walk around in the world, we don't have these external reminders that hey here's this subtraction, it's also a good way to make things better. The things we subtract are often invisible. We don't notice them or we It's also a good way to make things better.
因为当添加了某些东西时，它就在那里，就摆在你面前，作为添加这个东西是带来改变的一种方式的证据。如果减去了某些东西，在极少数情况下添加了东西，它就在那里，就摆在你面前，作为添加这个东西是带来改变的一种方式的证据。如果减去了某些东西，在我们确实这么做并坚持到底的极少数情况下，它根据定义已经消失了。所以当我们在世间行走时，我们没有这些外部提醒，嘿，这里有一个减法，这也是让事情变得更好的好方法。我们减掉的东西通常是看不见的。我们没有注意到它们，或者我们……这也是让事情变得更好的好方法。
The things we subtract are often invisible. We don't notice them, or we quickly become used to their absence. And so we fail to appreciate how these innovations, like Anna Kytland's building blocks, are affecting our lives. But sometimes, inventors can find clever workarounds to this obstacle. Inventors can find clever workarounds to this obstacle. Back in the 1970s, an aerospace engineer named Marion Rudy came up with the idea of using air to provide cushioning in running shoes. It was a classic moment where less added up to more.
我们减掉的东西通常是看不见的。我们没有注意到它们，或者我们很快习惯了它们的消失。因此，我们无法体会到这些创新，比如安娜·凯特兰的积木，是如何影响我们的生活的。但有时，发明家可以找到巧妙的方法来绕过这个障碍。发明家可以找到巧妙的方法来绕过这个障碍。早在20世纪70年代，一位名叫马里昂·鲁迪的航空航天工程师提出了在跑鞋中使用空气来提供缓冲的想法。这是一个“少即是多”的经典时刻。
But there was a problem. You couldn't actually see this innovation in action. It was inside the shoes. Marion Rudy kept bringing the idea to shoe companies, and they kept turning him down. He finally got to Nike, which at the time was kind of this boutique outfit that just served elite runners. And as the story goes in Nike lore, Phil Knight took him out for a run, liked what he felt, and then Air went into the Nike shoes. But for, even after the Air was in the shoes, nobody could see it. And so, but the Nike really started to take off,
但有个问题。你实际上看不到这项创新在发挥作用。它在鞋子里面。马里昂·鲁迪不断向制鞋公司提出这个想法，而他们不断拒绝他。他终于找到了耐克，当时耐克还是一家只服务于精英跑者的精品公司。正如耐克传说中的故事那样，菲尔·奈特带他去跑步，喜欢他脚下的感觉，然后空气技术就被应用到了耐克鞋中。但是，甚至在气垫加入鞋子之后，也没有人能看到它。所以，但耐克确实开始腾飞，
they had this kind of seminal shoe, the Air Max One, and those shoes were one of the first models that actually displayed the air. So they have the little window on the side so you could see, hey, in fact, there's air in here. And that made the subtraction noticeable and it was something that made Nike shoes different from any other kind of shoe
他们有这样一款具有开创性的鞋子，即Air Max One，这些鞋子是第一批真正展示气垫的鞋子之一。所以它们在侧面有一个小窗户，这样你可以看到，嘿，事实上，这里面有空气。这使得减法变得引人注目，这是让耐克鞋区别于任何其他鞋子的特点，
and kind of helped launch them on the path that took them to where they are today. Of course, you know, there's a guy named Michael Jordan who helped. So we've looked at how external crises can sometimes be a driver of subtraction and how increasing the noticeability of subtraction, the value of subtraction can help us embrace subtraction. You've also thought about other systems in some ways
并且某种程度上帮助它们开启了走向今天的道路。当然，你知道，有一个叫迈克尔·乔丹的人提供了帮助。所以我们探讨了外部危机有时如何成为减法的驱动力，以及如何提高减法的显眼度、减法的价值如何能帮助我们拥抱减法。你也考虑过其他一些系统，在某些方面
that can incentivize people to focus on subtraction. Tell me about your stop doing list, Lydie. A stop doing list is essentially the same as a to do list, except for you're thinking of things that you're not going to do anymore. And how I use it is whenever I do my to do's, which I try to do on a weekly basis, I also force myself to come up with equivalent number of stop doings,
可以激励人们关注减法。跟我讲讲你的“停止做清单”吧，莉迪。“停止做清单”本质上和“待办事项清单”一样，除了你考虑的是你将不再做的事情。我是这样使用的：每当我制定待办事项时（我通常每周做一次），我也会强迫自己列出数量相当的“停止做事项”，
which kind of makes sense, right? If you're gonna add new stuff to your day and assuming you're already at capacity, you need to also figure out what you're going to take away. Are there any specific things on your stop doing list that you have? I'm curious in terms of your stop doing list, what are the things that you put on? One that's been really helpful for me is it's basically a stop editing. And this is I read a lot of my students writing and it can be really tempting to just go through
这某种程度上说得通，对吧？如果你要给你的日程添加新东西，并且假设你的负荷已经饱和，你需要同时弄清楚你要去掉什么。你的“停止做清单”上有什么具体的事情吗？我很好奇，就你的“停止做清单”而言，你都放了些什么？对我来说非常有用的一项是，它基本上是“停止编辑”。这是因为我阅读很多学生的写作，如果只是通读并做出我想要的所有修改，会非常具有诱惑力。
and make all of the changes that I would want to make. But of course, that's not really helpful to them. And so I like I'll set a limit. I'll say, okay, give this student the 10 most important comments for this piece of writing. And it works really well. I mean, it saves me time one, but it also kind of rewards students who do more, right? So if the student gives you a really polished piece of writing, I still force myself to come
但当然，这对他们并没有真正的帮助。所以我喜欢设定一个限制。我会说，好吧，给这位学生的这篇习作提供10个最重要的评论。这效果非常好。一方面这节省了我的时间，但它也某种程度上奖励了做得更多的学生，对吧？所以如果学生交来一篇非常精炼的文章，我仍然强迫自己想出
up with 10 ways to make it better. Whereas if somebody doesn't put as much time in and gives you this really rough first draft, I don't spend all my time getting that to the same place that the other piece of writing is. Another example is just meetings. Meetings are the classic thing where I am providing some marginal value by attending a meeting or by calling a meeting, but not considering what could be done in that time. So I think oftentimes my stop doings are directed at meetings that I'm attending, but also the ones that I'm calling and asking other people to attend for me. Can you talk a moment about the role of subtraction in public policy? and asking other people to attend for me. Can you talk a moment about the role of subtraction in public policy?
10个让它变得更好的方法。而如果有人没有投入那么多时间，交出了一个非常粗糙的初稿，我就不会花所有的时间把那篇论文改到和其他文章一样的水平。另一个例子就是会议。会议是一个典型的例子，我通过参加会议或发起会议提供了一些边际价值，但没有考虑在这段时间里可以做些什么。所以我认为很多时候，我的“停止做事项”是针对我正在参加的会议，还有那些我发起并要求其他人替我参加的会议。你能谈谈减法在公共政策中的作用吗？并要求其他人替我参加的会议。你能谈谈减法在公共政策中的作用吗？
When we think about legislators, for example, we think about legislators as people who make laws, whereas you might argue that a crucial part of what legislators ought to be doing is pruning back laws that might no longer be useful. Yeah, I did some digging into how much laws have grown over time and by some measures, they've grown even faster than our economy.
例如，当我们想到立法者时，我们认为立法者是制定法律的人，而你可能会认为，立法者应该做的一个关键部分是修剪掉那些可能不再有用的法律。是的，我深入研究了法律随时间增长的程度，通过某些衡量标准，它们的增长速度甚至超过了我们的经济。
So it's just like all these things have this adding trend and laws are no exception. And it's the same as the building of civilization. When you don't have roads, it makes sense to add them. But once you've kind of been adding roads for a while, there are more opportunities to take them away to reveal pristine water. And so the laws, you know, we've kind of accumulated,
所以就像所有这些事情都有这种添加的趋势一样，法律也不例外。这与文明的建设是一样的。当你没有道路时，添加道路是有道理的。但一旦你添加道路有一段时间了，就会有更多的机会拆除它们以展现清澈的水流。因此，法律，你知道，我们一直在积累、
accumulated, accumulated, and we're left with a bunch that are redundant. And so some places have actually required legislators to, when they come with a new law, also come with two that are on the books that they want to get rid of. And that kind of rule can be really helpful. I mean, it's saying, look, you're a competent legislator if you do this. Lydie has been struck by the fact that subtraction can play a surprisingly powerful role in medicine.
积累、积累，结果留下了一堆多余的法律。因此，一些地方实际上要求立法者在提出新法律时，也必须提出两条他们想要废除的现行法律。这种规则真的很有帮助。我的意思是，这等于说，听着，如果你这样做，你就是一个称职的立法者。莉迪对减法在医学中可以发挥令人惊讶的强大作用这一事实印象深刻。
Doctors and nurses often have so much going on that simplifying rules and reducing complexity can actually improve patient outcomes. Yeah, my sister's a medical doctor and she was actually taught by this guy, Peter Pranovoost. And what Pranovoost was interested in was improving the practice of inserting central line catheters. So these are those thin plastic tubes that are used to draw blood or administer fluids and medication. Catheters are ubiquitous in American hospitals, and they're also one of the most common sources of infection. And it's not a sexy topic, certainly, but these infections were actually causing about 30,000 deaths each year in the United States, roughly as many as car accidents. And it's a complicated process. There are dozens of steps requiring thought and judgment and skill, and it's different based on the person. If you've got a 10 year old who's dehydrated,
医生和护士往往有太多事情要处理，以至于简化规则和减少复杂性实际上可以改善患者的治疗效果。是的，我姐姐是一名内科医生，她实际上是由这个人彼得·普罗诺沃斯特教导的。普罗诺沃斯特感兴趣的是改进中心静脉导管的插入操作。这些是用来抽血或输液和给药的细塑料管。导管在美式医院中无处不在，它们也是最常见的感染源之一。这当然不是一个吸引人的话题，但这些感染每年在美国实际上导致大约30,000人死亡，大致相当于车祸死亡人数。这是一个复杂的过程。有几十个步骤需要思考、判断和技能，并且根据个人的不同而有所不同。如果你有一个10岁脱水的孩子，
it's a different process than inserting one on a concussed offensive lineman, for example. To prevent the infections, Pronovost and his team considered all of this complexity, but then they proposed a very simple recipe. They, they gave a checklist and it's that medical professionals would wash their hands with soap, clean the patient's skin with antiseptic, put sterile drapes over the entire patient,
这与在脑震荡的进攻线卫身上插入导管是不同的过程。为了防止感染，普罗诺沃斯特和他的团队考虑了所有这些复杂性，但随后他们提出了一个非常简单的方案。他们提供了一份检查清单，即医疗专业人员要用肥皂洗手，用防腐剂清洁患者皮肤，在整个患者身上盖上无菌单，
wear a sterile mask, hat, gown, and gloves, and put a sterile dressing over the catheter site. And those very simple steps have brought striking results. It's almost entirely eradicated catheter infections and it saved thousands of lives. We've talked at some length about how addition is psychologically pleasurable and subtraction is often psychologically painful. One of your really interesting insights is that we should all try to reframe losses, subtractions, as additions. And there's an author you like who preaches this message.
戴上无菌口罩、帽子、手术衣和手套，并在导管部位敷上无菌敷料。这些非常简单的步骤带来了显著的结果。它几乎完全根除了导管感染，并拯救了数千人的生命。我们已经详细讨论了为什么加法在心理上是令人愉悦的，而减法在心理上通常是痛苦的。你一个非常有趣的见解是，我们都应该尝试将损失和减法重新定义为加法。有一位你喜欢的作家就在宣扬这个信息。
Here's a clip of her. The important thing about tiding is not choosing things to discard, but choosing things to keep. So, how do you choose what to keep? If the item sparks joy, keep it. If it does not, get rid of it. I take it you're a fan of the tidying guru, Marie Kondo. Yeah, a reluctant fan. I mean, as a professor, I felt like,
这里是她的一个片段。整理的关键不在于选择要丢弃的东西，而在于选择要保留的东西。那么，你如何选择要保留的东西呢？如果这件物品能激发喜悦，就留着它。如果没有，就摆脱它。我想你是收纳大师近藤麻理惠的粉丝吧。是的，一个不情愿的粉丝。我的意思是，作为一个教授，我觉得，
oh, I can't be a Kondo acolyte. But talking about our research, people would keep bringing her up. So I said, I gotta figure out what she's writing about. And, you know, of course her tone and observations advice are very spiritual, but through trial and error in this, her specific context, tidying,
哦，我不能成为近藤的追随者。但在谈论我们的研究时，人们总是不断提起她。所以我说，我得弄清楚她写的是什么。而且，你知道，当然她的语气、观察和建议都非常精神化，但通过在这个特定的背景——整理——中的反复试验，
she's derived some tips that are pretty scientifically sound. For example, her core message, right, is sparking joy. Default home organization advice is like, get rid of the stuff you don't want that doesn't fit. And she flipped it around. She said, keep what sparks joy and get rid of everything else. And so she's kind of steering us around loss aversion there, knowingly or not, because she's focusing us on this,
她总结出了一些在科学上相当健全的建议。例如，她的核心信息，对吧，是“激发喜悦”。默认的家居收纳建议是，摆脱你不想要、不合身的物品。而她把它颠倒过来了。她说，保留那些能激发喜悦的东西，摆脱其他一切。所以她不知不觉地引导我们绕过了损失厌恶，因为她让我们专注于
you know, this future vision of the tidy space. And sure, it's a little painful to get rid of these individual things, but you're just thinking of them as one component that's going to improve the overall situation. I understand you've also looked at artists, writers, musicians, painters, who've also thought deeply about subtraction.
这种对整洁空间的未来愿景。当然，摆脱这些单独的东西有点痛苦，但你只是把它们看作将改善整体情况的一个组成部分。据我所知，你还研究过艺术家、作家、音乐家、画家，他们也对减法进行了深入思考。
What have you found, Lydie? I mean, it's hard to find an expert who doesn't have some counterintuitive, seemingly counterintuitive advice on how to subtract, right? So Picasso defining art is the elimination of the unnecessary. And then you've got the little prince's author saying, perfection's achieved, not when there's nothing more to add, but when there's nothing left to take away. We talked about strunk in white, omit needless words.
你发现了什么，莉迪？我的意思是，很难找到一个专家对如何做减法没有一些反直觉的、看似反直觉的建议，对吧？所以毕加索将艺术定义为消除不必要的东西。然后小王子的作者说，达到完美不是当没有更多东西可加的时候，而是当没有东西可拿走的时候。我们讨论过斯特伦克和怀特的《风格的要素》：省略不必要的词语。
This goes way back. I mean, you've got William of Ockham of Ockham's razor fame. And his quote is that, it's in vain to do with more what can be done with less. And then a quote that gets attributed to Lao Tzu, to attain knowledge, add things every day, to attain wisdom, subtract things every day. And that's two and a half millennia back. And I think I learned a ton from these new and old profits of subtraction but the main
这可以追溯到很久以前。我的意思是，你有以奥卡姆剃刀闻名的威廉·奥卡姆。他的名言是：用较少的东西可以做好的事情，用更多的东西去做是徒劳的。还有一句归功于老子的名言：为学日益，为道日损。那已经是两千五百年前了。我想我从这些减法的新旧先知身上学到了很多，但主要的
takeaway is that they're the exceptions proving the rule right their advice endures because we are still neglecting subtraction. Lydie Klotz is a professor of engineering at the University of Virginia. He's the author of Subtract, The Untapped Power of Less. Lydie, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me. HIDDEN BRAIN is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Christian Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick and Nick
收获是，它们是证明规则的例外，对吧？他们的建议之所以经久不衰，是因为我们仍然在忽视减法。莉迪·克洛茨是弗吉尼亚大学的工程学教授。他是《减法：少即是多的隐藏力量》一书的作者。莉迪，非常感谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。Hidden Brain 由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯蒂安·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克
Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains executive editor. If you missed any of the episodes in our Innovation 2.0 series, you can find them in this feed or at hiddenbrain.org. If you enjoyed today's conversation about how to innovate through subtraction, please be sure to share it with a few friends. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是 Hidden Brain 的执行编辑。如果你错过了我们“创新 2.0”系列的任何一集，你可以在这个动态中或在 hiddenbrain.org 上找到它们。如果你喜欢今天关于如何通过减法进行创新的讨论，请务必与几位朋友分享。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。回头见。该剧集尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。